I'm Chris waters and I'm constantly
streaming entertainment on my mobile
device but what good is entertainment on
the go when it's not very mobile your
phone connects to the cell network using
its wireless modem and when it comes to
being mobile the modem makes the
difference not all modems are created
equal and that's especially important
when streaming is expected to grow four
hundred percent by 2020 with over 200
million mobile gamers in our community
the challenge with mobile gaming
entertainment is everything we want to
do requires multiple connection hops our
signal has to travel from device to
tower tower to hub hub to game serven
very still following all in order to
connect multiple players around the
world the modem is what keeps the device
connected tightly to the network or
leaves it hanging by a thread those darn
network drop offs might cause our screen
still rings or our games to start
lagging meaning we'll miss and
opportunities absolutely not cool
qualcomm technologies is a world leader
in device modems the Snapdragon x12 LTE
modem has the ability to use more LTE
connections to boost download speeds up
to 600 megabits per second and upload
speeds up to 150 megabits per second it
is also capable of shifting from LTE to
Wi-Fi whichever is stronger to deliver a
superior gaming experience fast
connections allow us to Game On the Go
basically lights were on our consoles
mobile gamers should demand higher
performance from their LTE modems
Snapdragon has Escobar to learn more
about how Snapdragon modems are changing
the mobile game visit w WK l calm calm /
the modem matters